consoles are becoming more and more like
pcs and according to a Sony executive
that means that PlayStation VR could
support PC someday Sony executive mas I
assume ito told the Japanese newspaper
DK that it isn't entirely out of the
question since playstation 4 shares a
lot of its internals with pcs the
possibility is there edo said as
translated by segment next keep in mind
that this is by no means a confirmation
that PlayStation VR will support pc but
Ito previously talked about a more
powerful PlayStation and it looks like
that's now happening ito stress that as
of now Sony is focusing on gaming
experiences for VR the company may look
to expand into other markets further
down the road at the moment we are
focused on games and were not ready to
make any announcements at this stage but
I'd say there will be an expansion into
various fields he said Sony wouldn't be
alone in expanding VRS reach beyond
games as oculus has stressed time and
again that VR has the potential to
impact and disrupt many other industries
outside of games playstation vr launches
in october and will retail for four
hundred dollars the headset will require
a camera which is sold separately but a
bundle is also available which includes
motion controllers and the camp for more
on VR including a detailed breakdown on
all the VR headsets and a review of the
recently released oculus rift head over
to gamespot com